Dear fellow scholars.
This is two minute papers with Dr. [inaudible]. If you have been watching this
serious for awhile.
You know, very well that I love learning algorithms and fluid simulations,
but do you know what I like even better learning algorithms applied to
fluid simulations. So I couldn't be happier with today's paper.
We can create wondrous fluid simulations,
like the ones you see here by studying the laws of fluid motion from physics
and right, the computer program that contains these laws.
As you see the amount of detail we can simulate with these programs is nothing
short of amazing. However, I just mentioned neural networks.
If we can write a simulator that runs the laws of physics to create these
programs, why would we need learning based algorithms?
The answer is in this paper that we have discussed about 300 episodes ago,
the goal was to show a neural network,
video footage of lots and lots of fluid and smoke simulations,
and have it learn how the dynamics work to the point that it can continue
and guess how the behavior of a smoke path would change over time.
We stopped the video and it would learn how to continue it if you will.
There's definitely is an interesting take.
As normally we use neural networks to solve problems that are otherwise close to
impossible to tackle. For instance, it is very hard if not impossible,
to create a hand-crafted algorithm that detects cats reliably,
because we cannot really write down the mathematical description of a cat.
However, these days we can easily teach a neural network to do that.
But this task here is fundamentally different. Here.
The neural networks are applied to solve something that we already know how to
solve. Especially given that if we use a neural network to perform this task,
we have to train it, which is a long and arduous process.
I hope to have convinced you that this is a bad, bad idea.
Why would anyone better to do that? Does this make any sense?
Well, it does make a lot of sense.
And the reason for that is that this training step only has to be done once and
afterwards querying the neural network that is predicting what happens next in
the simulation runs almost immediately.
This takes way less time than calculating all the forces and pressures in the
simulation while retaining high quality results.
So we suddenly went from thinking that an idea is useless to being
amazing. What are the weaknesses of the approach? Generalization,
you see these techniques,
including a newer variant that you see here can give us detailed simulations in
real time or close to real time.
But if we present them with something that is far outside of the cases that they
had seen in the training domain, they will fail.
This does not happen with our handcrafted techniques only to AI based methods.
So onwards to this new technique,
and you will see in just a moment that a key differentiator here is that is
generalization capabilities are just astounding. Look here.
The predicted results match, the true simulation quite well.
Let's look at it in slow motion tool so we can evaluate it a little better
looking great, but we have talked about superior generalization.
So what about that? Well,
it can also handle sand and goop simulations.
So that's a great step beyond just water and smoke.
And now have a look at this one.
This is a scene with the boxes it has been trained on,
and now let's ask it to try to simulate the evolution of significantly
different shapes. Wow.
It not only does well with these previously unseen shapes,
but it also handles their interactions really well,
but there is more,
we can also train it on a tiny domain with only a few particles.
And then it is able to learn general concepts that we can reuse to
simulate a much bigger domain and also with more particles.
Fantastic. But there is even more,
we can train it by showing how water behaves on these water ramps,
and then let's remove the ramps and see if it understands what it has to
do with all these particles. Yes, it does.
Now let's give it something more difficult. I want more ramps.
Yes. And now even more AMS.
Yes. I love it. Let's see if it can do it with sand too.
Here's the Ram for the training and let's try an hourglass now,
absolute witchcraft, and we are even being paid to do this.
I can hardly believe this.
The reason why you see so many particles in many of these views is because if we
look under the hood,
we see that the paper proposes a really cool graph based method that represents
the particles and they can pass messages to each other over these connections
between them. This leads to a simple general and accurate model.
That truly is a force to be reckoned with. Now,
this is a great leap in your own network based physics simulations,
but of course not, everything is perfect.
Here is generalization capabilities have their limits. For instance,
over longer timeframes solids may get incorrectly deformed.
However, I will quietly note that during my college years,
I was also studying the beautiful Navia Stokes equations.
And even as a highly motivated student,
it took several months to understand the theory and write my first flute
simulator.
You can check out the thesis and the source code in the video description,
if you're interested and to see that these neural networks could learn something
very similar in a matter of days,
every time I think about this shivers ran down my spine.
Absolutely amazing what a time to be alive.
This episode has been supported by Lambda. If you're a researcher or a startup,
looking for cheap GPU compute to run these algorithms,
check out Lambda GPU cloud. I've talked about Lambdas,
GPU workstations in our videos,
and I'm happy to tell you that they are offering GPU cloud services as well.
The Lambda GPU cloud can train image net to 93% accuracy
for less than $19.
Lambda's web based IDE lets you easily access your instance right in your
browser.
And finally hold onto your papers because the Lambda GPU cloud costs
less than half of AWS and Azure.
Make sure to go to Lambda labs.com/papers and sign up for
one of their amazing GPU instances today.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.